[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau bat aby
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
philippe bonnel pour laura antonelli
n'existe plus un roman enquête sur
l'existence mystérieuse de la star la
plus attachante et la plus sexy du
cinéma italien des années 70 et je
reçois l'historien gabriel martinez gros
qui nous propose une relecture des
croisades
avec son nouveau livre de l'autre côté
des croisades l'islam entre croisés et
mongol mais commençons d'abord par notre
époque qu'est ce qui caractérise ce
début de xxième siècle voici leurs
réponses en images on commence par la
vôtre gabriel oui palmyre une une ville
romaine en fait la capitale d'un royaume
arabe allié de roms dont elle avait
adopté les canons esthétiques une ville
qui a été âprement disputées pendant la
guerre civile syrienne entre l'état
islamique et le pouvoir syrien qui a été
reconquise après presque deux ans
d'occupation de l'état islamique qui
avait pratiqué de nombreux dégâts
humains et matériels par la syrie aidés
par les russes et où a eu lieu
véritable concert de d'un concert de
musique classique donc de musique
occidentale donnée par un orchestre
russe
une sorte de reconquête de la ville par
la civilisation mais des islamistes
dirait par la civilisation occidentale
ce qui n'a fait qu'accroître encore les
craintes du du grand remplacement
historique que représente pour les
islamistes cette présence d'eads et des
ruines d'une civilisation qui n'est pas
la leur sur leur sol voilà il ya un pas
qu'il n'y a pas qu'en france qu'on ya
donc pas qu'en france qu'on parle de
regrets en remplacement on en parle
aussi du côté arabe mais oui mais oui ce
dont on ne demandera pas confiance aux
consciences en général ans en france et
ce sont des craintes qu'il ne faut pas
négliger en tout cas que
l'historien ne peut pas écarter d'un
revers de main il est là pour les
expliquer et autant que possible et les
apaiser sans doute mais elles existent
déjà en l'occurrence du côté arabe il
s'agit moins d'une du grand remplacement
démographique de ce grand emplacement
historique c'est à dire de ces
civilisations que les occidentaux font
sortir de terre qui ont précédé l'islam
et qui menacent le remplacer avec la des
traîtres bien entendu c'est à dire en
particulier des chiites des iraniens et
avec la participation active des des
russes sur l'occurrence a pas le mien et
quand avoue philippe brunel vous avez
choisi une photo de diego maradona très
très belles photos d'ailleurs alors
pourquoi maradona oui enfin jarre
préféré qu'on voit une photo de maradona
avec son médecin pourquoi pour pour
parler de la fin de maradona c'est en
vérité c'était pour parler d'un de son
médecin qui s'appelle léopold ii au look
est le médecin qui l'a opéré au début du
mois de novembre d'un hématome au
cerveau et qui après s'est affichée dans
l'est dans les médias à travers des
selphy auprès de maradona chez lui
maradona porte sur toutes les photos des
blues depuis d'hôpital il a un pansement
les cheveux et le médecin lui seul 8
il serre la main se montrent cap sa
lumière se met dans sa dans la propre
lumière de l'icône argentine
il se présente un peu comme son sauveur
et puis quelques temps plus tard comme
maradona est mort dans d&co dans des
conditions assez mystérieuse parce qu'il
n'avait pas de cardio
il n'y avait pas de déformer fait
défibrillateur il était tout seul dans
une résidence
il n'y avait pas contrairement à ce qui
avait été demandé y avait pas
d'ambulance devant chez lui pour
l'emmener en cas de de malaise cardiaque
parce qu'ils avaient des antécédents
cardiaques
le sommet ce médecin il ya eu donc une
enquête de l'ats delà de la police
argentine qui a saisi un whatsapp du
médecin qui se réclamait de deux
luthiers de maradona dans lequel ils
conversent avec la psychiatre qui
s'occupait du footballeur argentin
et là il dit or je crois qu'il a eu un
un arrêt cardiaque et qu'il est sur le
kid est sur le point de mourir
ce grâce au nil disgrâce tonnes en
italien ça veut dire ce gros ce gros
lard quasiment c'est assez méprisant et
donc avec l' enquête on a découvert en
vérité la véritable nature des relations
du médecin avec avec maradona et j'ai
voulu cette photo c'est vous
cet épisode pour dire un peu vous m'avez
demandé un peu le style de notre époque
le style c'est un peu chacun veut veut
sa part chacun une sorte d'obsession
delà de l'heure come on peut dire une
obsession de de la façade de l'apparence
les gens veulent apparaître veulent
veulent marquer leur présence au monde
en faisant des selles fille en même
temps les selphy son mensonge et voilà
je voulais je voulais simplement parler
de ça 2 2 on est on est dans un
brouillage d'image en permanence enfin
en tout cas les celles ci peuvent servir
à installer une réalité mensongères et
donc fictive puisque on est là pour
parler d'un roman pourquoi
voilà c'est un vaste sujet en effet et
bien commençons
[Musique]
clic busnel laura antonelli n'existe
plus vient de paraître chez grasset
c'est un roman dont l'héroïne est la
star de malicia de ma femme est un
violon de sexe food dino risi de mon
dieu comment suis-je tomber si bas de
comencini de l'innocent de visconti
c'est l'adorable lorente délit que le
narrateur votre narrateur est chargé par
un producteur de retrouver longtemps
après sa gloire alors qu'elle vit
pauvres et est recluse dans la banlieue
de rome
alors la question que je ne peux pas ne
pas vous poser philippe brunel c'est
quelle est la part de réalité
en ce qui vous concerne c' est ce que
vous l'avez vraiment rencontré lorsque
vous étiez adolescent et qu'elle était
tôt au sommet de sa beauté et qu'elle
vivait à paris avec jean paul belmondo
et ils avez-vous vraiment revu à la fin
de sa vie non la part de réalité je les
croise et quand j'étais jeune mais je
les ai vus à la fin de sa vie oui je
suis allée chez elle elle m'a reçu chez
elle
oui je pense probablement un des
derniers visiteurs qu'elle a eue oui
comme ça mais je suis resté vingt
minutes avec elle on a fumé les
cigarettes j'étais très intimidée
c'était une sorte de de nos rencontres
on est resté comme ça presque dans une
sorte de silence un peu épais et à la
fin au moment où elle s'est levée comme
pour dire qu'en vérité ça y est la
visite était terminée avant avant de me
laisser partir elle m'a dit 'mais mais
l'acteur est ce qu'il est et jean paul
est ce qu'il joue toujours
c'est à dire elle était vraiment en
dehors de toute réalité elle même
et elle voulait quand même avoir des
nouvelles de jean paul belmondo qui est
donc l'acteur que que je n'écris pas son
nom dans le roman parce que c'est pas
c'est pas l'histoire de bêlements de
jouer les bras qui lui donne le premier
rôle
c'est l'histoire de leur antonelli c'est
pas l'histoire de leur histoire que je
veux pas m'y mets jeu comme en mêlée
c'est trop intime
la particularité de leur antonelli
c'était son physique adorable angélique
très juvénile et la facilité on peut
dire avec laquelle elles se
déshabillaient à l'écran à une époque où
c'était beaucoup moins courant qu
aujourd'hui notamment en italie
c'est vraiment pour moi ce qui ce qui
marque sa présence au cinéma
sur le plan historique oui vous avez
raison en même temps ça répond à un
contexte historique c'est dans l'espace
dans les années 70 c'est la fin de la
comédie italienne avec les grands films
de gassmann sordi de toute une
génération antoniazzi qui elle même la
comédie italienne répondait un peu
onéreux réalisme c'était pour remettre
un peu de la comédie de l'autodérision
dans la vie dans la culture italienne
et là il ya les années de plomb il ya
les premiers attentats il ya là une
autre qu'un climat de un climat
d'insurrection il ya l'attentât de de
bologne il ya bientôt les brigades
rouges qui se forme en 70 c est pour
répondre à ce climat le bientôt
l'enlèvement d'aldo moro et pour
répondre à ce climat il ya un cinéma qui
secret qu est un cinéma les gels et de
légèreté qu'on appelle la comédie
érotique que que beaucoup d'acteurs 10
des comédies de décolletés effectivement
il ya quelques égérie à djanet vis
fennecs est déjà la plus en vogue et
puis arrive leur antonelli qui trouve sa
place dans très rapidement qui
effectivement se dénude relativement
facilement qui est la première à se
dénuder vraiment à l'écran dans malizia
quand elle enlève quand elle remonte sa
jupe sa blouse de sa blouse de mai de
ménagères et effectivement ça fait
s'installe une nouvelle sensualité là
une nouvelle image de la spa menti toute
une génération de domme italiens sont
allés voir ce film je crois qu'il a fait
11 millions d'entrées il a fait 5
milliards de recettes
ça a été le comme un phénomène en italie
qui arrive on va dire en contraste avec
la réalité sociale et 10 ou 12 ans ou
quinze ans après brigitte bardot qui en
france avait un peu on vers suscité le
même phénomène et la même curiosité
alors malicia s'est pas seulement en
italie 1 c'est dans toute l'europe ça ça
va marquer toute une génération de deux
petits garçons
c'est d'ailleurs une photo de malicia
convoi juste derrière moi c'était pas
très très bon film mais elle va plus
loin que de montrer ses cuisses ou son
décolleté elle se met complètement nue
dans m'a dit tiens
et comme c'est pour séduire un
laissant évidemment ça a fait rêver
quantité de deux adolescents de cette
génération
malisse et avant mali tient on la
connaît en france parce qu'elle a joué
dans la mariée les mariés de l'an ii
avec jean paul belmondo puis dans
docteur popaul une infâme comédie de
claude chabrol toujours avec jean paul
belmondo et puis à tous ces films dont
vous parlez mais qu'on n'avait pas vu
nous et après mali siens elle va séduire
les grands cinéastes
en fait elle devient luigi comencini
dino risi c'est que ce fou c'est un film
à la gloire des formes de la route
adélie
oui oui c'est ça joue aussi resco là
avec boloni elle va jouer avec et
visconti va la valve a désigné comme la
plus belle femme du monde
un visconti un peu crépusculaire qui va
l'engager pour l'innocent le oui elle
incarne quelque chose quelque chose de
nouveau et le en fait elle était
considérée par les gens de son milieu
professionnel comme une très grande
actrice mais il n'en reste il reste pas
une grande trace d'elle sa filmographie
est effectivement vous l'avez vous
l'avez souligné n'est pas très bonne
on se souvient plus des titres de ses
films que des films même hélas pas elle
a marqué le cinéma dit en marge du
cinéma c'est assez étrange mais enfin
c'est comme ça et il reste un regard une
beauté une silhouette sur le fond
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas la preuve on
en parle encore aujourd'hui c'est même
elle n'a fait elle n'a fait que passer
là vont dire est qu'elle n'a pas
vraiment imprimé mais en même temps par
sac sexualité par la question qu'on se
pose ce sont fous les questions vous
poser et auxquelles vous répondez en
grande partie dans ce livre c'est qui
est elle vraiment c'est ça au fait que
l'on que l'on se demande sur leurs
antonelli qu'on voit si légère si libre
sur les écrans de cinéma et on se
demande mais qui est-elle en réalité
est-ce qu'elle était aussi libre dans sa
vie que l'était à l'écran ce qu elle
était intelligente
peut-être qu'elle faisait de son argent
comment vivent-elles sa célébrité c'est
toutes les questions qu'on se pose donc
au fond se pose votre narrateur
oui oui il y répond en partie parce
qu'en vérité comment on peut savoir qui
comment cerner autrui comment comment
comment comprendre les autres quand on a
du mal d'ailleurs à se comprendre
soi-même c'est une quête au on est
toujours finalement ça se termine
toujours par une forme d'échec je pense
un roman c'est une sorte de denquête sur
la vie alors c'est une enquête sur ce
qu'elle a été mais avec ce qu'on pouvait
savoir d'elle je coiffe et une enquête
très fouillée jupe allait rechercher
très profondément dans l'it dans les
archives s'était pas tellement mon but
d'ailleurs je crois pas moi au au
biographe lit je crois pas aux archives
je crois pas aux j'étais journaliste moi
même assez longtemps pour savoir je
crois pas trop à la matière
journalistique enfin je lui fais pas une
confiance absolue parce qu'on n'écrit
pas les choses souvent dans l'instant il
faut un peu de recul il faut du temps il
ya il ya un moment pour écrire les
choses et ce moment là finalement se
présente de façon toujours un peu un peu
brouillonne trop tard on on saisit mal
les gens donc le narrateur oui il essaye
de poser toutes les questions vous avez
posé là ce qu'il est réussi
j'en sais trop rien mais c'est ce qu'on
peut savoir de quelqu'un quand quand
quand cette personne n'est plus là pour
s'expliquer elle même mais il a la
chance de rencontrer pas mal de gens qui
l'ont bien connu et alors est ce que
vous les avez rencontré est ce que ce
sont vraiment les gens que vous décrivez
est ce qu'ils ont si bien connu que ça y
en a par exemple qui dit que l a pas
arrêté de tromper l'acteur qui en fait
jean paul belmondo avec elle est restée
à tambre d'année alors ils les mêmes et
elle n'arrêtait pas de le tromper
effrontément
voilà ce genre d'assertion est ce qu'on
peut lui faire confiance qui quelle que
soit la personne qui vous l'a qui
voulait dit d'ailleurs un oui oui je
comprends très bien votre question c'est
d'ailleurs la gêne la gêne qui peut y
avoir à écrire quand on s'intéresse à la
vie des autres c'est compliqué la vie
des autres ne nous appartient pas sur le
fond chacun le droit un peu à sa part de
pas citer alors on rentre dans cette pas
si tu es là des gens vous confient des
choses je suis allé voir réellement ces
gens
vous aurez pas embarquer dans le genre
d'aventuré riz des personnages factice
non ils ont ils m'ont vraiment confié ce
qu'il pensait d'elle après ça vaut ce
que vaut le témoignage humain
pas plus il ya aussi des choses que je
me suis refusé d'écrire qui aurait pu
éclairer davantage le personnage mais je
voulais rester en surface parce que sur
le fond ce qui est intéressant c'est
c'est plutôt ce que suggèrent les gens
que plutôt que ce qu'ils sont ce qu'ils
sont ça leur appartient enfin c'est un
peu c'est un peu ça donc on reste un peu
en lisière en marge mais peut-être que
là dans une forme de un peu de confusion
c'est jamais très clair mais en même
temps c'est peut-être ça la vérité de la
rente antonelli c'est un personnage
complexe peut-être pas clair avec
elle-même d'ailleurs est donc tout est
là ces relations sur jean paul belmondo
les témoins que j'ai rencontrés m'ont
certifié que c'était le grand amour de
sa vie et qu'une part de parce que à la
fin donc sur le fond sa véritable
histoire c'est qu'elle elle a vécu
recluse dans un appartement pendant les
25 dernières années de sa vie il part il
semble que la rue la rupture avec jean
paul belmondo il soit pour beaucoup
alors ce qu'il skiait oscille sans doute
pour beaucoup c'est son arrestation elle
oriente et délires 1991 l'a déjà 49 ans
la police se trouve chez elle 169 doses
de cocaïne et
elle avait l'air d'en prendre depuis
longtemps mais ce que vous montrez bien
dans votre livre c'est qu'en fait elle
est véritablement piégés par la police
la police va se faire de la publicité
sur le dos d'une d'une star un peu déçu
parce que le cinéma italien toute façon
est mort à ce moment là et elle même sa
carrière s'est arrêtée en 91 elle est
encore très populaire et on l'arrête
pour la traîne devant le tribunal
quoi oui oui tout à fait c'est le le
ministère de la justice la police d'état
fin l'état italien feu a lancé des
perquisitions des actions d'éclat pour
montrer qu'il était agissant justement
dans cette période dans ce contexte un
peu lourd du terrorisme des brigades
rouges pour montrer qu'ils agissaient
quand même quelque part il ya eu
beaucoup de perquisitions d'arrestation
un peu sommaire le il n'y a pas qu'elle
il ya eu altercation était un
un grand acteur italien qui était aussi
le partenaire dans la vie de lagardère
ce trailer et qui dirigeait le théâtre à
milan il est le mode burger le compagnon
de visconti qui a été aussi arrêtés et
qui lui a fui directement en autriche
pour se soustraire à la police elle elle
s'est fait piéger un acteur français
connaîtra la même mésaventure quelques
années plus tard qui s'appelle pierre
clémenti qu'ea qui a écrit d'ailleurs
sur cette histoire il a fait deux ans de
prison à rome où il y avait ses actions
elle a été piégée par un maréchal qui
lui même voulait probablement se faire
de la publicité sur son dos qui l'a
arrêté la nuit il était à minuit passé
sans le mandat de perquisition
elle lui a ouvert gentiment sa porte et
lui elle a même pas cherché à cacher
l'héroïne qu'elle avait dans unique dans
une poubelle et elle s'est fait arrêter
et après on se rend compte qu'en fait
cet homme se marie chanel avait connu
quelques temps auparavant elle en avait
plus vraiment un souvenir très précis
alors peut-être que lui c'est sûr des
relations qui s'étaient peut-être mal
chine il a voulu se venger en france et
pas trop tout ça et reste très troublée
moi je le laisse dans le groupe parce
que je pense que la confusion est aussi
le la marque un peu les relations
s'entrecroisant faryab il ya plein de
liens entre les gens qui sont difficiles
à démêler je cherche pas vraiment les
démêlés parce que je crois pas qu'ils
aient de vérité quelque part alors autre
moment tragique c'est quand elle va
tourner malicia 2000 maliciels retour
malicia numéro 2 elle est beaucoup plus
âgée la et l approche les 60 ans et on
lui demande une opération de chirurgie
esthétique qui tourne mal
elle est défigurée elle disparaît
complètement là oui c'est ça on peut à
peu près fait une réaction allergique au
collagène nodem de cuisson là on la
reconnaît plus
elle et elle devient difforme laurent
antonelli disparaissent ou une nouvelle
écosse où un nouveau corps elle grossit
elle prend du poil va en hôpital
psychiatrique je pense qu'après elle
coupe avec le monde
elle se réfugie dans dans un appartement
à la dispo lié à 40 km au nord de rome
dans un appartement dans un immeuble
banal
elle va y passer 25 les 25 dernières
années de sa vie dans une forme de
redire de deux quiétisme de elle va
chercher peut-être la sérénité dans la
dans la religion une sorte de paix de
l'âme
en tout cas elle le serait elle veut
plus elle veut plus participer en fait
c'est comme ça que je vois les choses
elle veut plus pâle elle n'est plus là
pour personne
elle a coupé avec le monde et et c'est
peut-être en même temps quand on y
réfléchit c'est peut-être la seule façon
de se révolter pour elle contre contre
les injustices qu'elle a subi alors elle
termine comme ça seul elle est morte sur
le dans son salon la nuit comme ça dans
un dernier écrit que la voisine a
d'ailleurs entendu perçu et puis voilà
une histoire se termine comme ça
pourquoi elle pourquoi elle a vécu
enfermée pourquoi cet enfermement elle
sait jamais vraiment expliqué elle non
plus là dessus
elle a dit qu'elle était qu'elle avait
redécouvert le dieu parce qu'en vérité
elle est l aide de dunes et du elle est
là elle a eu une éducation très
religieuse par ses parents et ses amis
ses proches pensent que sur le fond est
là elle a développé un sentiment de
culpabilité d'avoir tourné tous ses
films inepte dont vous avez parlé à avec
exactitude c'est à dire se déshabiller à
l'écran ça peut-être pas été aussi
facile que ça voilà mais à l'époque je
pense qu'elle n'avait pas d'autres
moyens d'être actrice que de se dénuder
à l'écran c'était le genre le genre en
vogue c'était une façon pour elle
d'exister dans son métier et elle a fait
pas que des mauvais films et jouer qu'on
voit parce qu'on a des photos de leurs
anthony autant profiter
on la revoit habillés en religieuses
c'est dans cette somme at on le sait que
ce fou vous l'avez dit elle était
devenue très croyante
à la fin de sa vie en tout cas elle
invoquait la religion catholique là on
la voit dans un an religieuse très sexy
1 mais 7,7
le fait qu'elle soit devenue très
croyante est-ce que évidemment on se dit
d'une façon un peu facile elle voulait
elle voulait se faire pardonner ses
péchés mais est-ce cabeza ou est ce
qu'il y avait quelque chose de plus
mystique chez elle là j'ai du mal à vous
répondre parce qu'il aurait fallu
évidemment parlé de ça avec elle je
pourrais probablement probablement parce
que quand même elle a résisté 25 ans
c'est pas il n'y a pas eu de retour en
arrière il n'y a pas eu de elle s'est
pas laissée séduire par la vie l epa
reste évidemment 25 ans enfermé
totalement au début elle sortait le au
petit matin vers 4 5 heures du matin où
aller chercher ces journaux pas plus et
puis après elle est restée enfermée elle
aurait pu très bien sortir parce qu'elle
était moi quand j'ai eu face à moi vous
reconnaissiez pas le retenir il aurait
pu se promener dans la rue sans que
personne ne se retourne c'était plus la
même femme après sur les véritables
motifs de son enfermement
oui probablement un retour vers la vers
la religion vers quelque chose
d'apaisant elle a peut-être trouvé
elle a dit elle m'a dit qu'elle se
sentait bien avec babineau babineau
c'était sa façon de dire avec dieu je
suis bien avec dieu j'ai besoin de rien
d'autre
c'est ce qu'elle m'a dit en tout cas
voilà sans de gros doit se contenter de
ça elle est morte en 2015
c'est quoi pour vous philippe brunel au
fond le plus grand mystère de la rente
delhi après avoir enquêté sur elle après
l'avoir retrouvée d'ailleurs et après
avoir écrit ce livre c'est quoi le grand
mystère celui vous aimeriez bien con
qu'on perce pour vous comprendre le
moment où tout a basculé
si peut-être dans une vie qu'elle nous
dise que peut-être dans une vie les
choses peuvent peuvent basculer un
moment de bascule parce que forcément il
y en a eu un
le
un moment où elle se retire de la ville
elle coupe avec les gens c'est quand
même un acte grave c'est un acte profond
qu'on peut pas traiter comme ça j'aurais
aimé parler de ça avec quand je les ai
vus quand on est resté là 20 minutes une
demi heure on n'a pas en a parlé quand
même un peu j'ai parlé de ses interviews
je disais vous étiez toujours juste avec
une recherche de sens danser dans ses
interviews alors que évidemment les
journalistes l'interrogeaient toujours
un peu sur sa sexualité sûr sûr sûr les
apparences sur sur sa beauté est sûr que
des choses un peu sur le fond a pour l
artificiel et je lui ai dit j'ai lu
quelques interviews vous étiez toujours
juste elle dit oui j'ai toujours essayé
de nous tromper personne
voilà alors peut-être elle s'est sentie
elles mêmes trompés par le par le monde
qui l'entourait c'est possible le
mystère c2c l a emporté un peu avec sa
mort c'est à dire c'est assez difficile
de percer le mystère des gens même même
de vous si demain je m'intéressais à
vous j'aurais du mal à percer votre
mystère en tout cas je l'espère mais
c'est fou ce qu'elle a fait signer
l'italie justement parce qu'elle était
très sexy parce qu'elle se elle tourner
nue justement sur sa sexualité c'est sa
sexualité qui est mystérieuse pour les
italiens quand elle s'est elle est
arrêtée et qu'on trouve de la cocaïne
chez elles au fond ce qui passionne le
plus les gens c'est pas tellement
qu'elles prennent de la coke et c'est
les soirées de débauche qu'on imagine
qu'elle donnait autour de sa piscine et
de la même manière les gens qui vous
parle d'elle vous parle constamment du
fait qu'elle avait beaucoup d'amants
qu'elle faisait ça comme ça qu'elle n'y
accordez pas beaucoup d'importance on
voit bien qu'on a projeté sur la femme
les les fantasmes qu'on avait sur
l'actrice oui mais vous n'avez pas
partiellement répondu
et qui dit les choses comme il faut les
dire tout à l'heure c'est à dire vous
avez vous avez posé cette question est
ce qu'elle était dans la vie comme sur
l'écran comme dans ses films et je pense
que tous les téléspectateurs pouvaient
imaginer ou peut-être espérer avoir une
aventure avec elle comme si elles
étaient tout comme si elle était sur le
fond un personnage qu'on pouvait
rencontrer demain dans la rue et qui
pouvaient enflammé quelque chose dans
votre propre vie
c'était pas c'était pas un ce n'était
pas un personnage qu'on voyait de loin
il y avait l installer comme ça même
elle dans son dans son jeu dans sa façon
d'être dans son naturel une certaine
forme de de familiarité d'ailleurs qui a
sans doute dû me toucher puisque sinon
j'aurais peut-être pas été aussi loin
dans cette recherche là d'une actrice
qui sur le fond m'a pas vraiment
intéressé enfin donc ça tout ça est
étrange je pense que les gens disaient
qu'ils devaient se dire peut-être si je
la rencontre demain tout est possible
c'est possible ça c'est à dire vous avez
bien posé la question et vous n'êtes pas
posé cette question enfin vous avez pas
eu cette impression vous même quand
elles deux les cendres vous l'avez
rencontrée en vrai à l'époque où elle
vit à paris avec jean paul belmondo et
c'est l'époque de malicia c'est l'époque
où tous les petits garçons rêvent de
rencontrer
laura antonelli vous ça vous est
vraiment arrivé oui je les croisais gelé
ça s'appelle pas une rencontre je les
croisais c'était une silhouette i l
était j'avais un ami qui vivait chez
jean enfin de jean paul belmondo était
son tuteur donc il ya eu un moment donné
on a croisé
oui je sais pas quand on est jeune on
n'a peut-être pas on n'est pas jean
sérien non j'ai pas été
non j'ai pu être non j'étais éblouie par
des tas de gens m'aimaient non pas par
elle laura antonelli n'existe plus c'est
le titre du livre de philippe brunel qui
vient de paraître chez grasset ont fait
une pause et on parle des croisades
[Musique]
gabriel martinez gros vous êtes
professeur émérite d'histoire de l'islam
médiéval à l'université de nanterre est
un disciple d'ibn khaldoun le grand
historien arabe du 14 14e 15e siècle
vous êtes l'auteur d' une brève histoire
des empires de l' empire islamique que
vous nous aviez raconté dans cette
émission les deux sont maintenant en
poche
et aujourd'hui vous publiez de l'autre
côté des croisades chez passé composé
c'est une nouvelle lecture des croisades
que vous nous proposez l' empire
islamique racontez-vous et de menacer
d'un côté par les chrétiens les francs
comme on les appelle l époque les
croisés et de l'autre côté par les
envahisseurs mongols
c'est vrai que nous quand on pense aux
croisades on voit les croisés partir à
partir à l'assaut de la terre sainte
mais on pense pas qu'il ya les mongols
aussi de l'autre côté
oui voilà le thème du livre c'est de
rétablir la centralité de l' empire
islamique en fait c'est ce n'est pas
nous qui sommes a priori dans l'esprit
en tout cas des des musulmans de ce
temps c'est à dire du 11e 12e 13e siècle
ce n'est pas nous qui sommes nous
occidentaux je veux dire nous francs
comme il nous désigne alors ce n'est pas
nous qui sommes sans trop s est bien sûr
ils sont les civilisations centrale
ils sont la civilisation tout simplement
avec un grand c est cette civilisation
est agressé par des peuples qui sont
dans un premier temps en tout cas perçu
comme barbare c'est à dire à la fois les
francs à l'ouest et l'est tu roulais
turco mongols surtout les mongols
évidemment parce que les mongols sont
payen à l'est et on pourrait même y
ajouter en tout cas il voudra donne lui
plus tard il ajoutera les berbères au
sud et donc le fait qu'il s'agisse des
invasions barbares éprouvés par la
concomitance de l'agression de ces trois
peuples 6
s'il ne s'agissait pas avant tout d'une
maladie de lempire ces invasions
n'aurait pas été absolument
contemporaine comme elles l'ont été
c'est bien parce que la bête impérial
est malade c'est bien parce que nous
sommes à la disent les auteurs arabes
que ces barbares ont réussi à envahir
lempire est donc juste l'initiative
vient de nous ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est ce que représente à ce moment là
le lempira raballand l' empire islamique
il est encore très très vaste 1 il est
il a été plus puissant qu'il mais bon là
mais il est encore gigantesques
il est encore gigantesques qui va encore
en gros de l'espagne à l'ouest à balad
un aux abords de lin de glisse l'un
commence à pénétrer l'un d'eux
militairement ce sont des turcs en
général qui commencent à pénétrer le le
pendjab et la vallée du gange donc
l'ouest et le nord-ouest de l'inde
à ce moment là c'est à dire au 12e
siècle
c'est à ce moment là que précisément
certains de ces turcs payen qu'on
appelle les des mongols participent à la
grande écrasement de dieu des terres
centrales et civilisée de l'islam avec
les croisés à l'ouest avait croisé et et
les mongols
alors justement ces peuples nouveau
parce qu'ils les appliquent des concerts
comme des peuples nouveau et les francs
et les mongols
alors en quoi sont-ils nouveau et quel
rôle joue t-il face à cet empire
ils sont perçus comme nouveau parce
qu'ils apportent une sève nouvelles de
violence barbare pour les empires la
violence et l'invasion barbare sont ou
comment dire à un risque du métier
1 la violence des barbares et simplement
la contrepartie de la civilisation du
désarmement des peuples sans trop de
lempire de leur productivité économique
de leur productivité intellectuelle
le lan la violence dont l' empire a
besoin dont il a besoin ne serait ce que
pour se défendre elle est apportée
généralement par des barbares d'au delà
des frontières de l' empire est donc ce
n'est pas ces invasions barbares qui
choque véritablement ce qui va choquer
petit à petit surtout dans le cas des
mongols et des francs c'est que ces
barbares sont inassimilables c'est ça le
problème
ce qu'on aurait attendu de ces barbares
c'est que il s'installe certes au proche
orient avec une certaine violence comme
d'autres l'avaient fait avant eux mais
qu'ils se convertissent à l'islam qu'ils
adoptent finalement les moeurs les
pratiques de la civilisation avec un
grand c c'est à dire de l'islam
or ce n'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas
c'est ça le grand danger des francs et
des mongols le problème c'est que ces
peuples ont déjà porté leur fascination
ailleurs ils ont déjà des civilisations
dont ils sont amoureux qui ne sont pas
l'islam pour les francs
ces roms tout simplement et pour les
mongols ce qu'on oublie souvent c'est la
chine
c'est d'abord la chine et est donc
ce qui est grave dans un cas comme dans
l'autre dans le cas des croisés comme
dans le cas des mongols c'est que il ne
cède pas à la fascination de l'islam
dans un premier temps qu'ils menacent
non seulement de d'envahir et d'écraser
l'islam et d'en changer la civilisation
dans pervertir totalement la
civilisation minable il faut bien se
souvenir que du temps de l'empiré romain
qui a connu les mêmes les mêmes cycles
que l' empire arabe qui lui succède en
voilà c'est au tour de la méditerranée
les les barbares ont joué le même rôle
et les barbares y compris quand ils ont
réussi à vaincre les romains se sont
quand même assimilé aux romains et nous
sommes devenus romain une fois qu'ils
ont mise
ils ont mis à bas les l'élan pire ils
sont devenus romain sait ce qu est ce
que c se vendrait au fond les historiens
les politiques arabes de l'époque kobe
benkhaldoun qui est là où à la fin du
xvème siècle et ils comprennent pas que
ça se passe pas de la même façon
exactement parce que le mécanisme normal
d'une invasion barbare c'est
l'assimilation à l' empire
les barbares le donnent l'assaut à la
civilisation que parce qu'ils en sont
fascinés jeudi quelque part que queval
la barbarie est un crime passionnel en
quelque sorte vous êtes le barbare d'une
civilisation parce que vous êtes fasciné
par cette civilisation et c'est pour ça
que vous l'envahissent est en fait c'est
pour ça que vous l'agresser c'est un
viol un quasiment et un viol qui se
termine en général par un mariage un
mariage entre la violence des barbares
et la civilisation mais là le
le mariage ne se produit pas du mois
avec les francs et il ne se produira
jamais une chose tout à fait bizarre et
qui pourtant pour les occidentaux par
est évidente c'est qu'aucun francs ne
s'est jamais converti à l'islam
parmi ceux qui partaient pour lorient ou
parmi les castillans qui était en train
de reconquérir al andalus 1 ou parmi les
normands qui envahissent et qui occupe
la sicile il va de soi pour nous que
bien sûr ils sont chrétiens roma il
parle de latin etc
mais mais mais pour ceux qui reçoivent
cette invasion et qui se considèrent eux
comme la civilisation dominante
il était incompréhensible qui ne se
convertissent pas à l'islam qu'ils ne
parlent pas l'arabe etc
il faut bien voir gabriel martinez go
qu'à cette époque là c'est vrai l'islam
est une civilisation extrêmement raffiné
et qu'on est des gros barbares à côté et
je parle là des francs et les mongols
aussi une vitalité il ya plein de choses
et une inventivité extraordinaire mais
on est beaucoup moins raffiné que mais
ce que vous montrez bien c'est qu'au
fond les chrétiens sont pas si fasciné
que sa part la civilisation islamique au
fond ils la comprennent pas très bien ce
qu'ils veulent c'est récupérer l'empiré
romain
ils veulent restaurer leur vie ils
veulent récupérer ce qui est à eux
jerusalem eux ce qui les intéresse c'est
le fait que jérusalem a été romaine
avant et qu'elle devrait donc revenir
chrétienne et il ne se pose pas du tout
d'autres questions au fond ils veulent
récupérer leur dû
voilà c'est tout à fait ça c'est bien le
grand danger pour l'islam j'entends
c'est le bien le grand manger des
croisades c'est que ces barbares ont un
sens en eux c'est à dire en général le
barbant n'a pas de sens il a tant de
civilisations qui ne va envahir le sens
qu'elle lui donne il va se convertir à
ça c'est assez birth à sa religion à sa
langue etc
or malheureusement ces barbares là ont
un sens en eux qu'ils aient le sens
romain en effet non seulement ils
veulent reconquérir jérusalem mais ils
veulent reconquérir en fait la
méditerranée et romain haas et il les
croisades font partie d'une entreprise
plus général qui est aussi à l'oeuvre en
sicile qui est aussi à l'heure en
espagne qui est aussi à l'oeuvre dans le
nord du maghreb et qui est la reconquête
du marenostrum sud de la méditerranée
puis il reconquiert aussi et de la même
façon dans les mêmes vues de la science
grecque un qui à leurs yeux leur
appartient parce que elle a appartenu à
l'antiquité gréco-romaine 7,7 sciences
mathématiques astronomique médicale elle
n'est pas perçue comme arabe même si
elle est passé par l'esprit des
des savants arabes du 9ème 10ème siècle
elle elle est perçue que
fondamentalement comme grec c'est une
récupération d'aristote de platon de
tous ces noms qui chantent déjà dans
l'esprit des occidentaux parce que ils
les ont appris à travers le latin bien
sûr à travers l'héritage de l'empiré
romain il on a perdu les oeuvres on l'a
gardée des noms et on veut maintenant
récupérer ses oeuvres dont on considère
en effet qu'elles appartiennent au
patrimoine de ce que l'occident appelle
lui la civilisation et qui est la
civilisation gréco romaine bien sûr et
non pas la civilisation islamique
les croisades sont aniche un échec un
pur pour les chrétiens en terre sainte
jérusalem restera musulmane jusqu'à la
fin de la première guerre mondiale
au fond donc c'est longtemps longtemps
après voilà et voilà les francs au fonds
font reculer l'islam en méditerranée
ménez ne pénètre pas le coeur de lempire
non en effet c'est un échec et
probablement c'est la conclusion que je
tente
c'est un échec parce que l'occident
réussi c'est à dire que une civilisation
bien établi une civilisation riche
puissante organisée comme l'est déjà à
l'occident du xiiie siècle n'a rien à
prendre ni à apprendre des autres
donc elle se referme tout naturellement
sur elle même après
une dilatation qui lui a donné tout de
même les îles de la méditerranée et le
contrôle à peu près totale de la mer
dans le cours du 12e 13e siècle par
l'intermédiaire des cités italiennes
mais pour le reste la france de saint
louis avec quasiment une vingtaine de
millions d'habitants dans les frontières
du pays d'aujourd'hui est un pays
gigantesque immense d'une richesse
considérable lorsque joinville le
compagnon de saint louis découvre les la
terre-sainte cela la palestine
il est surpris comme probablement
beaucoup mais lui il écrit par la
pauvreté de la terre sainte
parce qu'il imaginait bien entendu une
terre de lait et de miel celle que
décrit la bible mais non par rapport à
l'occident ou aux campagnes de
l'ile-de-france du xiiie siècle
lorient est très et au total très pauvre
en tout cas les villes sont encore ont
encore un certain éclat un aspect comme
vous l'avez dit tout à fait remarquable
il ya des genres et des savants en
particulier tout à fait remarquable en
orient mais les campagnes en particulier
sont redoutablement pauvres si on les
compare déjà à celle de l'île de france
ou de la picardie ou de la normandie
tout simplement il ya des villes
fascinant qu'il y'avait cordoue on me le
corno
c'est la plus grande ville de rouen est
une ville arabe c'est le sait la
capitale du du califat de cordoue
c'est une ville magnifique que plus
peuplés plus riche plus belle que la pop
c'est à new york de l'an mil grenache
ses sublimes ya d'amalia bagdad
mais on en approchera pas de d'abbas est
de bagdad un emploi non parce que le la
société et l'état islamique comme tous
les états impériaux c'est la même chose
en chine prélève par l'impôt sur ces
campagnes d des revenus beaucoup plus
élevé que ne l'est le prélèvement
seigneurial en occident et donc les
villes qui sont en très large part
alimenter irrigué par l'impôt sont
beaucoup plus vastes au 6 mai en chine
que dans le monde islamique
quand l'occident en revanche les
campagnes sont plutôt plus prospères en
occident probablement au xiiie siècle
qu'elles ne le sont dans le monde
islamique
alors voyons maintenant l'impact de
l'invasion mongole et là l'impact il est
beaucoup plus grand 1 sur ce grand
empire islamique donc qui a commencé à
se développer au viiie siècle et qui à
la fin du xvème siècle est la fin du
moyen-âge va être considérablement
réduit alors quel est cet impact sur le
kazakhstan le turkménistan l'ouzbékistan
l'azerbaïdjan tout ça au fond c'est le
produit des invasions mongoles
tout à fait tout à fait le on a du mal
aujourd'hui à imaginer de la puissance
de l'impact de ces invasions mongoles
on ignore dans un premier temps pourquoi
d'ailleurs une telle violence a été
déployé par les mongols puisque
les mongols ont vraiment pratiqué une
extermination des populations qu'ils
conquérait ce qui est à l' inverse de ce
que font la plupart des envahisseurs la
plupart des envahisseurs n'envahisse
encore une fois que parce qu'ils sont
fascinés par la civilisation qu'ils
envahissent et en général ils sont là
pour exploiter le travail et donc la vie
de ceux qui l'ont conquis et soumis dans
un premier temps les mongols extermine
et dans le monde islamique
ils vont continuer à exterminer pendant
une quarantaine d'années alors qu'en
chine ils ont cessé d'exterminer c'est
parce que les mongols se sont rangés
enfin en tout cas les branches mongols
qui l'ont emporté dans les luttes de
succession après la mort de jadis quand
leurs fondateurs se sont rangés du côté
chinois et donc les dernières
extermination dans les quarante
cinquante ans après la mort de deux
jeunes jusqu'en porte au détriment de
l'islam et elle elle vise à restaurer
l'unicité du commandement de lempire
mongol chinois dont le siège désormais à
pékin donc ces invasions dans l'islam
ont été monstrueuse elles ont
véritablement désertifier ou contribué à
désertifier d'autant qu'ils aiment
plusieurs vagues qui se sont succédé qui
ont repris même
après les premières grandes vagues du
xiiie siècle ont repris au 14e siècle
avec tamerlan elles ont fait
probablement des des centaines de
milliers peut être des millions de morts
ce qui est gigantesque évidemment dans
un monde qui est beaucoup beaucoup moins
peuplées qu'aujourd'hui on estime qu'au
milieu à la fin du xiiie siècle
il ya peut-être 350 millions de d'êtres
humains sur la terre et donc cesser
c'est sans comparaison avec les
croisades bien entendu on parle de la
violence des croisades mais il n'ya il
n'y a rien que de très ordinaire en inde
en dans la violence des croisades très
ordinaire ou au temps et aux guerres que
l'islam se livré à lui-même un cocker
qui se déroulaient à l'intérieur de
l'islam
en revanche les invasions mongoles
déchaîne une violence dont on n'a pas
d'idée lorsque bagdad est prise en 1258
on dit que le massacre puisque
l'extermination totale de la population
a été décidé a duré 17 jours
dix sept jours et 17 nuit bien sûr on
estime et c'est une estimation
conservatrice un modéré on estime à une
centaine de milliers c'est à dire la
totalité ou la quasi-totalité de la
population de bagdad qui était alors
très déchu par rapport à ce qu'elle
avait été quelques siècles auparavant
une centaine de milliers le nombre de
victimes ce qui encore une fois est
gigantesque car il faut multiplier par
20 par 30 pour avoir l'équivalent de ce
que serait aujourd'hui une extermination
de ce genre qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
l' empire ottoman par exemple will tear
ottoman qui va arriver qui va prendre
constantinople en 14 153 cm mais nous et
eux il est génial mais m 2 il a
quasiment 20 ans il veut prendre
constantinople on lui dit ça va être
facile en deux ans il le prend et il
prend la capitale du saint-empire romain
germanique c'est à dire la nouvelle
byzance énorme
la révolution est considéré mais en quoi
cet empire ottoman qu'est-ce que l'
empire ottoman
qu'est ce que ces turcs doivent aux
influx aux invasions mongoles
avec les invasions mongoles on te
pousser en avant c'est à dire vers
l'ouest puisque les mongols viennent de
l'est
ils ont poussé en avant donc ils ont
poussé vers l'ouest un nombre
considérable de tribus d'ethnies turcs
dont celles qui ont fini par donner
naissance à l'émirat d'abord ottoman ou
14e siècle ça a commencé très
modestement
puis au fur et à mesure que les ottomans
se sont implantées dans les balkans
l'empiré ottoman jusqu'à la chute de
constantinople en 1453 pratiquement tout
ce qui se passe à l'est de la syrie donc
irak iran azerbaïdjan asie centrale et
les lisières de l'inde tout ce qui se
passe là entre le 13e et le xvème siècle
xvième siècle 10 ans et d'origine
mongole les alors il faut dire qu'après
que les branches principales des mongols
ce soit si j'ose dire converti à la
civilisation chinoise et manifester
toute leur fascination pour la
civilisation chinoise et qu'ils aient
établi à pékin le centre de leur empire
d'autres branches qui avait été éliminée
dans cette lutte de pouvoir entre
mongole est rejetée en général plus au
nord vers les steppes se sont elles
converti à l'islam et ce sont elles qui
plus vigoureuse
comme le veut le système d'ibra donne
plus vigoureuse que ceux qui se sont
avachis dans les douceurs de la
civilisation vont dominer effectivement
aux 14e et au xvème siècle c'est de ces
vagues laqué tissu le fameux tamerlan
qui va constituer un immense empire
d'une puissance destructive absolument
colossal mais aussi une très raffiné
étrangement une civilisation très rapide
et autour de cette capitale de
samarcande et c'est en particulier de
cet art qu'on appelle timouride dollar
qu'il a que lui même et ses descendants
on fait élaborer à savoir quand que ce
qu est issue la quasi-totalité de l'art
islamique à partir du xvième siècle ce
soit en inde où l'islam s'implante de
plus en plus radicalement que ce soit en
iran que ce soit en turquie avec l'
empire ottoman donc tient tamerlan que
qui s'appelle timour timur le boiteux
même voilà et et timur le boiteux qui
est à la fois le concurrent le plus
sanguinaire de l'histoire et qui va
accoucher d'un d'un empire considérable
puisque en du mois les dont les
conséquences vont être considérables
puisqu'elle a faim l' empire ottoman va
remplacer lempire arabe au fond de
l'empiré ottoman va s'étendre là on se
souvient de 14 153 la prise de
constantinople mais y'a 15 117 la prise
du caire
et quand les français vont débarquer en
algérie celle empire ottoman qui étaient
là avant s'avance faire pendant des
siècles l'empiré ottoman va être le
grand empire
le descendant l'héritier de l'empiré
islamique tout à fait cc c'est
pratiquement le grand paradoxe de la
théorie des bras donne c'est à dire plus
une invasion et barbare plus elle est
violente et plus elle bonne ce elle se
décompose comme une matière fissile se
décompose et plus elles se décomposent
en donnant une grande civilisation très
étrangement c'est à dire que les grandes
civilisations sont issus en général des
peuples les plus sauvages et des
invasions les plus meurtrières ou les
plus grandioses la vision arabe aux yeux
de divers cadeaux et l'invasion turco
mongols
oui bien sûr c'est cette c'est un
paradoxe qu'il a été parmi les rares à
poser dans la civilisation mais
probablement parce que l'histoire de
l'islam était assez particulière elles
avaient été torturées littéralement un
en particulier par c'est par ses
conquêtes mongol dont il est encore
puisqu'il du contemporain de tamerlan il
va rencontrer tamerlan la fin de sa vie
lorsque taverne ans
qui était le spécialiste des montagnes
de tête vous savez une fois qu'ils
avaient plus les villes lui aussi
faisait pratiquer systématiquement des
exterminations dans des villes qui ne
comptait pas continuer à tenir dans son
empire il ramenait tout ce qu'il y avait
d'intéressant à samarcande en
particulier les artisans et il extermine
est systématiquement le reste est donc
ils rencontrent ils ne rencontrent
tamerlan au moment où il apprit damas en
1401 et il
ça représente à peu près le quart les
deux semaines qu'il a passées auprès de
tamerlan représente le quart du récit
autobiographique il a fait ce qui ce qui
est dire le l'impact que tamerlan a eu
dans son os sur son sur son esprit et
est en gros où il il dit j'ai rencontré
le fléau du monde
j'ai rencontré le maître du monde j'ai
vu comment se faisait l'histoire j'ai eu
pour la première fois en face de moi
l'histoire en train de se faire et on
dit d'ailleurs que tim moore lui avait
proposé de travailler pour lui d'être
son mémorialiste est ce que c est ce que
c'est vérifier ce qui s'est avéré ça que
ça dit oui oui c'est extraordinaire que
le plus grand conquérant de l'époque et
rencontrer le plus grand historien après
qu'il se soit parlée et qu' il lui fait
des offres d'emploi s'est quand même
fait fantastique et il lui a fait
quelques oeuvres d'emploi il y avait un
obstacle considérable dont on ne vont
pas parlé jusqu'ici c'est que eelv a
fait don de parler l'arabe et que
tamerlan ne parlait pas
tamerlan ne parlait que le persan mis sa
part le turc de ses origines bien
entendu sa langue de culture
c'était déjà le persan tout l'est de
du monde islamique et c'est aussi une
des conséquences des adhésions mongol
tout l'est du monde islamique et qu'on
vous jusqu'à jusqu'à l'irak parle
désormais ou du moins les chancelleries
les administrations le pouvoir les cours
par le persan et donc il y a non
seulement une différence de langue
qu'ils ont besoin d'un traducteur pour
pour se comprendre là l'autre il ya non
seulement une différence de langue mais
une différence de culture parce que tu
as verlan à une culture persane qui
voudraient 12 n'a pas et inversement ils
veulent donner à une culture arabe
traditionnel que tamerlan n'a plus qui
n'a jamais su refaire que les que les
milieux culturels autour de tamerlan
même non plus à ce moment-là c'est semer
en effet et dernier mot gabriel est ce
que les francs les chrétiens les croisés
ce qu'ils ont dit une notion du danger
de l'importance que revêtent les
invasions mongoles elles sont là est-ce
qu'on est conscient oui on en est
conscient l'europe d'ailleurs a été
touché à la marge par ces invasions
mongoles en russie en pologne en hongrie
on en a eu très peur mais les invasions
mongoles se sont assez vite détournée de
l'europe parce que l'europe justement ne
représentait pas pour c'est entre
guillemets babar mongol une civilisation
intéressante ce qui les fascine et
c'était la chine et donc ils ont fait
porter l'essentiel de leurs efforts sur
la chine est très secondaire mans sur
l'islam et nous avons été sauvés par
l'autre signifiance tout simplement
alors une fois que les mongols ont été
prouvé leur premier échec face aux
musulmans ils ont cherché à faire
alliance avec les francs en particulier
à partir de la vie de l'époque de saint
louis et et un peu au-delà
mais cette alliance n'a rien donné merci
gabriel martinez gros de l'autre côté
des croisades ça vient de paraître chez
passé composé
et je rappelle que vos deux précédents
livres
eux sont en poche dans la collection
points merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]